having said that let's make some noise
for your headliner the guy you came to
see are you guys ready yes let's get it
going
you seen him on Conan he's stealing
tonight's show Netflix all over please
welcome stage two very funny mr. mark
Normand hey comedy huh we're really
doing it oh boy this is wild I've been
off 86 days now I'm back and I don't
know how I ever did this [ __ ] this is
terrifying I just got nothing but
swastikas here so I don't know what to
do but I'm just a comedian telling jokes
bear with me folks I am rusty I'm
nervous but we're gonna have fun you
know it's been it's been a while but
we'll be well be better right all right
take a look take it easy that's nice
built a little make-a-wish II but um
good to be here in the Dallas what a
town huh it's hot hot fun fun I might
not I'm coming from New York you know
I'm my whole city's a [ __ ] garbage
fire right now it's the epicenter of
Corona we got riots and [ __ ] feels like
the 60s race riots
we just went to space and the president
has a head shot I feels weird to do in
Dallas but yeah I know they used to be
called me from New York like I'd go to
cities they were like thanks for coming
here from New York all the way and I
hope you were like thanks for you know
getting my grandma's sick you piece of
garbage yeah but we'll have fun a lot of
jokes a lot of [ __ ] bear with me there's
a lot of crap here but you guys are
living the good life you know
everything's locked up in New York I
went to a restaurant today I feel like
an Amish guy I'm like lights look at
this holy [ __ ] I got my hair cut in the
backyard last week I'm a
I'm a mess all right how you doing hey
you look familiar
yeah all right that's always a bad sign
when I know every one of my fans by face
all right cool yeah all right here we go
corona jokes what what a time we're
living in I hope we get the antibody
test I don't know who knows you know is
probably immune of this [ __ ] is uh the
two girls one cup chicks I feel like I
feel like they're gonna be fine you know
those girls can take a lickin just so
I'm rusty in every way I'm out of shape
you guys have gyms yet to those open
what Wow you guys are [ __ ] bananas
holy hell good for you yeah you got the
gym why don't we go me gyms up there I'm
all mushy and gay you know I'm uh yeah I
am out of shape I haven't been this out
of shape since the gyms were open ya
know things are tough yeah but I mean
it's business as usual I'm paying for a
gym membership we're not going so
nothing's really that different but yeah
working on it you gotta wear your mask
now everybody's got the masks let's be
honest some people need a muzzle Jesus
Christ shut the hell up stop yelling at
me you know we corona is so weird it's
like a horror movie like if you're out
of the ozarks at the pool you're [ __ ]
evil you're gonna get it but if you're
protesting you'll be all right what's
the difference it's like the disease
knows you're doing good or not you know
it's all very kooky and now we're just
sitting at home watching Netflix for six
months you know like everyone's like
what are you watching I'm watching my
life pass me by [ __ ]
all right I'm dying here it's brutal
everything's weird now our strip clubs
open here really so do the chicks have
no clothes on but are wearing a mask
that seems weird like hey here's a
sloppy 20 I'll put my nose in your
butthole but don't cough on me [ __ ] are
you crazy
everything's backwards but I'm lucky to
be here this is a great gig is a great
club and next week I'm playing a target
in Minneapolis so uh that could go
either way you know yeah so thanks for
having me people are getting angry this
is everybody's pent up everybody's
worked up you know some people are mad
at Asian people Asian people love the
riots they're like woo it's off us for a
minute yeah Jesus Christ yeah I saw a
bunch of people online are saying racist
[ __ ] to Asian people I'm like look if
you're gonna type a bunch of racist [ __ ]
to Asian people don't do it from an
iPhone all right have some respect for
the kid who made it alright oh that's
gonna get a lot worse buckle up folks
all words we're all gonna die one day I
mean this is a tough time in history for
black people black people are going
through it the two people have a tough
right now we're black people and women
named Karen they're having a tough go
but yeah yeah poor black women there
they're there yeah they got hit hard by
the disease you know which I'm shocked
by cos black people are so strong I'm
surprised I thought they'd be fine with
illness I mean look at Magic Johnson
he's still kicking right he's doing
great hell he beat Kobe I know who saw
that coming
yeah you got a live life folks yeah I
know black people are getting sick I
blame institutionalized racism and
elaborate handshakes come on those
things all this [ __ ] that had to catch
up at some point you know all right yeah
yeah yeah yeah I felt horrible when I
saw what happened in Minneapolis the
rights out there I got I didn't know
they were black people of Minnesota I
had no idea I've been there like 10
times I've ever seen one black person
but you know everybody wanted their
business reopened well the looters did
that they just did it through the glass
you know but uh
they're open all right here we go ah-ha
okay yeah yeah fun times weird times you
know they interviewed r.kelly about it
he was like cope in 1902 old for me but
um yeah ah boy I hate myself I don't
know what's going on the whole country's
nuts Jimmy Fallon got in trouble for
blackface like like what are we doing
that was 20 years ago
why we mad at Jimmy Fallon the TV show
put it out NBC approved it there was a
writers room why is it was 20 years ago
you know what I was doing 20 years ago I
was banging a 16 year old ha ha ha you
can't judge stuff by a later date I was
I was also 16 20 years ago
if you didn't don't call the police or
blog or whatever all right I think we're
all sick of this [ __ ] though we're all I
mean the Coronas kind of like the check
engine light you know when you first
hear about you're like damn this is
terrifying and after a while you're like
[ __ ] I gotta get to work ha ha ha this
is too much yeah some people didn't buy
it though my uncle he looks at corona
like it's the tooth fairy's like I know
this is all made up but I'll take the
free money
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a crazy country we live in you know
eventually all this will be over you
know it's something to look forward to
eventual all be over
you know the pandemic will end the
police brutality will end and then we'll
be right back to school shootings you
know what a what a nation these poor
kids I got to go to school at home now
they gotta have home schooling every kid
how long till a teacher in Florida [ __ ]
one of her students ha ha cyber sex
though cyber sex I've [ __ ] that up I
thought you guys will be wearing masks
this is nice to see you know there's so
many masses I hate the masks I can't I
can't tell which women need to be
smiling all right yeah things have
gotten crazy then we got a big election
coming up big election coming up I think
I'm gonna vote for Biden but I don't
know anything about the guy all I know
is it feels like the guys running an
entire presidential campaign on having a
cool black friend uh-huh seems like all
I know about him is he's like kind of a
creep Oh old dude you know if he's
wearing a mask how's he gonna smell
those little girl's hair I don't yeah
yeah how's that gonna work out louis c.k
don't eat a bunch of money to Biden and
Biden said no thanks I was like what
he's like he's a creep like yeah but so
are you ha ha you're not gonna take his
money what about you yeah that's like
Chris Brown going I can't watch MMA you
know that's crazy I can't do it yeah
that's too much that's violent you know
hmm
yeah Joe Biden what a kook I can't wait
till he meets Greta Thune Berg can we
get those two together you know have him
creep out on her you know he hugs her
for too long it's like is it global
warming or is it hot in here she's like
how dare you all right I think we've had
enough of it
whoo baby doll that was a it comes right
back I mean 85 plus days out whatever
it's panic just I was nervous and it's
like I hate to use the old cliche it's
like riding a bike you just get up there
and you're like oh pedaling again and
then you know it's like oh [ __ ] I'm
doing it and then you get scared and you
just go hey don't even think about it
and just just sit back in the water I
would never have taken that much time
off I was forced to take time off as we
all are and it may just makes you
appreciate I I do this every weekend
heywait became like autopilot and then
to go back up there after 80 days be
like oh my god this is so amazing what
I'm doing I wrote this and they're
laughing and it's flowing and the lights
and the crowd and beautiful thing I'm
getting sappy and creepy up here but uh
it's good to be back